in terms of the value now that you're
creating this how does that process go
so the skin of the shaft the penis was
used to form part of the labial skin so
it was almost pulled back like a banana
um yeah so yeah and when I saw that I
was just honestly blew my mind and I
couldn't believe how much it just looked
like a vagina so when people say oh I
didn't realize so it's my job to know
and I have been in Spain this girl came
over she looked like Shakira I'm dancing
with Shakira right and I feel there's
two soldiers in this battle no that's
how I looked at her and I think when I
looked at she knew I knew and at that
point she kind of pushed me against the
wall you judge me she knew she knew and
I wasn't I wasn't I was just taken back
oh I would know I would know my friends
surgery is so detailed today in the
changes to the face the body and
everything else you wouldn't know the
true Geordie podcast